♪ (music) ♪
So hi, everyone!
Hope everybody had a good lunch.
I'm Sarah Sirajuddin.
I'm an engineer on TensorFlow Lite team.
And I have my colleague,
Andrew Selle, also on the same team.
We're really excited today
to talk to you about all the work
that we've been doing
to bring machine learning
to mobile devices.
So in today's talk,
we'll cover three areas.
First, we'll talk about
how machine learning on-device
is different and important.
Then we'll talk about all the work
that we've been doing on TensorFlow Lite.
And lastly, we'll talk about
how you can use it in your own apps.
So before that, let's talk
about devices for a little bit.
Usually when we say "device,"
we mean a mobile device,
basically a phone,
and our phones are with us all the time.
These days they have lots of sensors
which are giving rich data
about the physical world around us.
And lastly, we use
our phones all the time.
Another category of devices
is edge devices,
and this industry has seen
a huge growth in the last few years.
So by some estimates there are
right now 23 billion connected devices--
so smart speakers, smart watches,
smart sensors, what have you.
And an interesting trend to notice here
is that technology
which only used to be available
on the more expensive devices
is now available on the cheaper ones.
So this rapid increase in the availability
of these more and more capable devices
has now opened up many opportunities
for doing machine learning on-device.
In addition to that, though,
there are several other reasons
why you may consider doing
on-device machine learning,
and probably
the most important one is latency.
So if you are processing streaming data
such as audio or video,
then you don't want to be making calls
back and forth to the server.
Other reasons are
that your processing can happen
even when your device is offline.
Sensitive data can stay on-device.
It's more power-efficient,
because the device
is not sending data back and forth.
And lastly, we're in a position
to take advantage of all the sensor data
that is already present on the device.
So all that is great,
but there's also a catch.
And the catch is that
on-device machine learning is hard.
And the reason it is hard
is that many of these devices
have some pretty tight constraints--
small batteries, low compute power,
tight memory--
and TensorFlow
wasn't a great fit for this.
And that is the reason
we built TensorFlow Lite,
which is a lightweight library and tools
for doing machine learning
on embedded and small platforms.
So we launched TensorFlow Lite
late last year in developer preview,
and since then we've been working
on adding more features and support to it.
So I'll just walk you through
the high-level design of the system.
So we have the TensorFlow Lite format,
and this is different
than what TensorFlow uses,
and we had to do so
for reasons of efficiency.
Then there is the interpreter,
which runs on-device.
Then there are a set of optimized kernels,
and then there are interfaces
which you can use
to take advantage of hardware acceleration
when it is available.
It's cross-platform,
so it supports Android and iOS,
and I'm really happy to say today
that we also have support for Raspberry Pi
and pretty much most other devices
which are running Linux.
So the developer workflow roughly is
that you take a trained TensorFlow model,
and then you convert it
to the TensorFlow Lite format
using a converter,
and then you update your apps
to invoke the interpreter
using the Java or C++ APIs.
One other thing
that I want to call out here
is that iOS developers
have another option.
They can convert
the trained TensorFlow graph
into the CoreML format,
and use the CoreML runtime directly.
And this TensorFlow to CoreML converter
is something that we worked on
together with folks who build CoreML.
So there are some questions
that are top of mind for people
every time we talk about TensorFlow Lite.
And the two most common ones are
is it small in size, and is it fast?
So let's talk about the first one.
Keeping TensorFlow Lite small
was a key goal for us
when we started building this,
so the size of our interpreter
is only 75 KB.
And when you include
all the supported ops, this is 400 KB.
Another thing that is worth noting here
is a feature called
selective registration.
Developers have the option
to only include the ops
that their models need,
and link those,
and thereby keep the footprint small.
So how did we do this?
First of all, we've been pretty careful
in terms of which dependencies we include.
And the second thing is
that TensorFlow Lite uses FlatBuffers,
which are more memory-efficient
than protocol buffers are.
And then moving on to the next question,
which is performance.
So performance...
super important goal for us,
and we made design choices
throughout the system to make it so.
So let's look at the first thing,
which is the TensorFlow Lite format.
We use FlatBuffers to represent models.
And FlatBuffers is this cross-platform
serialization library
that was originally developed
for game development use cases.
And since then it's been used in other
performance-sensitive applications.
The advantage of using FlatBuffers
is that we are able
to directly access data
without going through heavyweight
parsing or unpacking steps
of the large files which contain weights.
Another thing that we do
at conversion time
is that we pre-fuse
the activations and biases,
and that allows us
to execute faster later on.
The TensorFlow Lite interpreter
uses static memory and execution plans,
which allows us to load up faster.
There are a set of optimized kernels
which have been optimized to run fast
on the NEON on ARM platforms.
We wanted to build TensorFlow Lite
so that we can take advantage
of all the innovations that are happening
in silicon for these devices.
So the first thing here
is that TensorFlow Lite supports
the Android Neural Network API.
The Qualcomm Hexagon DSP driver
is going to be coming out soon,
as part of the Android P
developer release.
And Huawei and MediaTek are
a couple of hardware renderers
who have also announced their integration
with Android Neural Network APIs,
so we should be seeing those
in the coming months as well.
Second thing here is
that we have also been working
on adding direct GPU acceleration,
and we are using OpenGL on Android
and Metal on iOS.
So quantization is the last bit
that I want to talk about
in the context of performance.
So roughly speaking, quantization
is this technique to store numbers
and perform calculations on them
in representations
which are more compact
than 32-bit floating point numbers.
And this is important for two reasons.
One, the smaller the model,
the better it is for these small devices.
Second, many processors
have specialized synthe instruction sets
which process fixed-point operands
much faster than they process
floating point numbers.
So a very naive way to do quantization
would be simply shrink
the weights and activations
after you're done training.
But that leads to suboptimal accuracies.
So we have been working
on doing quantization at training time,
and we have recently released
a script which does this.
And what we see is that,
for architectures
like Mobilenet and Inception,
we are able to get accuracies
which are fairly similar
to their floating-point counterparts
while seeing pretty impressive
gains in the latencies.
So I've talked about a bunch
of different performance optimizations.
Now let's see what do all
of these translate to together
in terms of numbers.
So these are two models
that we benchmarked,
and we ran them
on the Android Pixel 2 phone.
We were running these with four threads
and using all the four
large cores of the Pixel 2.
And what you see is that we are seeing
that these quantized models
run more than three times faster
on TensorFlow Lite
than their floating-point counterparts
run on TensorFlow.
So I will move on now and talk about
what is supported on TensorFlow Lite.
So currently it is limited
to inference only,
although we are going to be working
on supporting training in the future.
We support 50 commonly used operations,
which developers can use
in their own models.
In addition, they can use
any of these popular
open source models that we support.
One thing to note here is
that we have an extensible design,
so if a developer is trying to use a model
which has an op
which is not currently supported,
they do have the option to use
what we call a "custom op," and use that.
And later in this talk
we will show you some code snippets
and how you can do that yourself.
So this is all theory
about TensorFlow Lite.
Let me show you a quick video
of TensorFlow Lite in practice.
So we took the simple mobile-like model
and we retrain on some common objects
that we could find around our office.
And this is our demo classification app
which is already open sourced.
As you can see,
it is able to classify these objects.
(laughter)
So that was demo.
Now let's talk about production stuff.
So I'm very excited to say
that we have been working
with other teams in Google
to bring TensorFlow Lite to Google Apps.
So the Portrait Mode on Android camera,
"Hey Google" on Google Assistant,
SmartReply on WearOS--
these are some examples of apps
which are going to be powered
by TensorFlow Lite in the coming future.
And with that,
I'm going to hand off to Andrew,
who will talk to you about
how you can use TensorFlow Lite.
Thanks for the introduction.
So, now that we see what TensorFlow is,
or TensorFlow Lite is, in particular,
let's find out how to use it,
let's jump into the code.
So the first step of the four-step process
is to get a model.
You can download that off the internet
or you can train it yourself.
Once you have a model,
you need to convert it
into TensorFlow Lite format,
using our converter.
Once that's done,
there might be some ops
that you want to spot optimize,
using special intrinsics
or special hardware
that is specific to your application,
or there might be ops
that we don't yet support.
You need to write custom ops for that.
Once all that's done,
you can go to your app
and you can write it
using the client API of your choice.
So let's look at the conversion process.
So we support input of SavedModel
or frozen GraphDef.
Once you have that, you can use
our Python API or a command line tool.
Here we're showing the Python interface,
so we give it a directory of a SavedModel
and it gives us a TF Lite FlatBuffer out.
Once that's done...
Well, before that's done,
there might be some things
that you need to use
to make this work better.
So the first thing is you need
to use a frozen GraphDef--
Or SavedModel is actually easier,
because it doesn't need to be frozen.
Second, we need to avoid
unsupported operators.
A lot of times a training graph
will have a lot of conditional logic
or checks that are really
not necessary for inference.
Sometimes it's useful to create
a special inference script.
Lastly, if you need to look
at what your model is doing,
the TensorBoard Visualizer
is useful for the GraphDef,
but we also have
a TensorFlow Lite Visualizer
to look at the FlatBuffers.
And looking at these compared
to each other can help you.
If you find any issues,
please file them with GitHub,
and we will respond to them
as we get needs.
So lastly, write custom operators.
So let's see how to do that.
To write a custom operator
in TensorFlow Lite is relatively simple,
and it involves defining four functions.
The main one is invoke.
So here I've defined an operator
that returns pi,
just a one scalar pi.
This is really useful.
So once you've done that
you need to register these new operations.
Now there's a number of ways
that you can register operations.
If you don't have any custom ops
and you don't need to do any overriding,
you can use the built-in Op Resolver.
But sometimes you might want to ship
a TensorFlow Lite binary
that's much smaller,
so you might want to do
selective registration.
In that case, you should ship
a needed ops resolver
or include your custom ops
in that same thing.
Once you have that op set,
you just plug it into the interpreter.
Okay, so now we've talked
about custom operations.
Let's see how we actually
put this into practice in the Java API.
So in Java you give it
your TensorFlow Lite FlatBuffer schema
to the constructor of Interpreter.
Once you've done that,
you fill in your inputs and outputs.
And lastly, you run run,
which will populate the outputs
with the results of the inference.
Really simple.
Next, how do I actually include this?
Do I need to compile a bunch of code?
We're working really hard to make it
so that you can use TensorFlow
from the pip,
and do all your training,
and then you don't need
to compile TensorFlow.
So one of the things we provide
is an Android Gradle file
that you can include,
and then you don't need to compile
your own TF Lite for an Android app.
We have a similar thing for CocoaPods
to run TensorFlow Lite.
So this will make it a lot easier to do.
So, now that we know
how to use TensorFlow,
let's look at our roadmap.
As we move forward,
we're going to add more ops
so we can support more and more
TensorFlow models out of the box.
Second, we're going to add
on-device training,
and we're going to look at
so you can do hybrid training--
some of it on the server,
some of it on your device,
wherever it makes sense.
That should be an option for you.
And third, we're going to continue
to improve tooling
to analyze graphs better,
to do more optimizations.
We have more than we can talk about
that we're working on,
but we hope that this small peek
of what we're doing
and what our basis is will make you
interested and excited to try it.
So, there's one remaining question left,
which is should I use
TensorFlow Mobile or TensorFlow Lite?
So TensorFlow Mobile is
a stripped down version of TensorFlow
that includes a subset of the ops.
Moving forward,
we're going to put all of our effort
into improving TensorFlow Lite
and improving its ability
to map to custom hardware.
So we recommend that you target
TensorFlow Lite as soon as possible,
if it's possible.
If there's some functionality
that you still need in TensorFlow Mobile,
let us know, and we'll work
to improve TensorFlow Lite
in a commensurate way.
Okay, demo time!
So nothing like a live demo, right?
So let's switch over to the demo feed,
and we'll talk about it.
So, we saw some mobile phones.
Mobile phones are really exciting
because everybody has them.
But another thing that's happening
is these edge computing devices.
So one of the most popular ones
that has emerged for hobbyists
is the Raspberry Pi.
So what I've done is built some hardware
around the Raspberry Pi.
So if we zoom in we can see
that we have the Raspberry Pi
mobile board.
And this is just a system on chips,
similar to a cellphone chip.
And one of the great things
about the Raspberry Pi
is that they're really cheap.
Another great thing is that
they can interface the hardware.
So here we're interfaced
to a microcontroller
that allows us to basically
control these motors.
These are server motors,
common in RC cars,
and they allow us to move the camera
left and right and up and down.
It's essentially a camera gimbal.
And then we have it connected
to a Raspberry Pi-compatible camera.
So, what are we going to do with this?
Well, we showed
the classification demo before.
Let's look at an SSD example.
So this is single-shot detection.
So what this can do is it can basically
identify bounding boxes in an image.
So given an image
I get multiple bounding boxes.
So, for example, we have an apple here.
And it identifies an apple.
Now the really cool thing
we can do with this is,
now that we have the motor,
we can tell it to center the apple.
So we turned on the motors now,
so now the motors are active.
And as I move it around
it's going to keep the apple
as centered as possible.
If I go up, it'll go up.
If I go down, it will go down.
So this is really fun.
What could you use this for?
Well, if you're a person,
it can also identify you.
So currently I have that filtered out.
So if I stand back
it's going to center on me.
So I could use this
as sort of a virtual videographer.
Imagine a professor
wants to tape their lecture,
but they don't have a camera person.
So this would be a great way to do that.
I'm sure that all the hobbyists around
can now use TensorFlow
in a really simple way,
can come up with many better applications
than what I'm showing here.
But I find it fun, and I hope that you do.
And I'm not an electrical engineer
or a mechanical engineer,
so you can do this too.
Alright.
So thanks for showing the demo.
Let's go back to the slides please.
So I had a backup video,
just in case it didn't work.
(laughter)
It's always a good plan.
But we didn't need it, so that's great.
Let's summarize.
So, what should you do?
I'm sure you all want to use
TensorFlow Lite.
Where do you get it?
Well, you can get it on GitHub,
right around the TensorFlow repository.
How you can find out about it
Is looking at
the TensorFlow Lite documentation
on the tensorflow.org website.
In addition, we're creating
a mailing list, tflite@tensorflow.org,
that you can email about some
of your issues and your ideas.
And we're also excited to hear
about what you use TensorFlow Lite for.
So, with that I hope
to hear from all of you.
One at a time, please, but...
(chuckles)
So with that I want to thank everybody,
thank Sarah for her presentation.
I thank your attendance,
everybody who's around the world
listening to this.
And, in addition, this was work
that we worked very hard
with other members of the Google team,
lots of different teams,
so there's a lot of work
that went into this.
So thanks a lot.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪